despite the anticipation for breath of
the wild sequel
nintendo has been dead silent about the
upcoming games since the release of the
announcement trailer
with zelda's 35th anniversary coming up
we're getting the feeling that something
may be coming soon so we've taken the
time to reflect on the first breath of
the wild to find 9 things that we'd want
to see from the upcoming sequel
if you want to stay on top of the latest
breath of the wild news make sure to
like and subscribe because we'll be on
it as soon as anything drops
partner bullzelda can we not have zelda
as a damsel in distress anymore wouldn't
it be cool to just fight alongside
her in a more cooperative experience
while the nintendo online system isn't
the greatest
nintendo has generally been good about
having adventures together with friends
with games like luigi's mansion 3 so
zelda and link side by side out in the
open world sounds like a dream come true
other ideas like having an ai controlled
zelda fight alongside you
and outright playable zelda instead of
link or even controlling both characters
simultaneously a la astral chain would
be interesting additions
just make her more involved somehow more
traditional zelda items
bomb chews the gale boomerang hook shots
and so many traditional zelda equipment
pieces will be interesting additions to
the breath of the wild sequel
we appreciate the effort that went into
adding callback items to the original
breath of the wild such as the big goron
sword and the twilight bow but zelda
fans are hungry and we always want more
nero mechanics while outright devil may
cry combat mechanics in a mainline zelda
game would be a bit
too much this new arm possessed link
gives me some serious nero vibes
i'm hoping that the arm has some
grappling abilities for exploration
puzzling and combat because that would
be outright awesome
and in the same vein as some zelda
equipment that should return a spiritual
successor to the hook shot would be more
than welcome
more traditional zelda dungeons we
wouldn't want to replace shrines
far from it but we're hoping the main
dungeon contained more of what made the
original zelda so memorable
maps compasses keys unique bosses maybe
even specific dungeon items
while the divine beasts were great they
really just felt like giant shrines
and since the divine beasts are
presumably conquered now is a time for
dungeons
bigger emphasis on story despite
everything breath of the wild did well
its story really took a back seat
especially towards the end
a toe was dipped into this with age of
calamity and we feel like it could be
even better
because the game was so focused on
allowing you to tell your own adventure
and do anything in any order there was
little room for the characters and story
to grow
and since collecting all the memories
were an optional part of breath of the
wild
some players missed out on even more
context to the story now that we're onto
the sequel we're hoping the game decides
to put more of an emphasis on the story
and its characters
allowing them to fully develop
throughout the course of the game this
might mean making the story more linear
but if the rest of the game is still
open then we think this won't be too
much of a compromise
especially if the story is good nintendo
has proven in the past with titles such
as wind waker and skyward sword that
there are some great stories to be told
in the zelda universe and with breath of
the wild specifically there's so much
more to zelda link in their relationship
so the sequel seems like the best place
to do this
explore new areas outside of hyrule or a
different version
hyrule in breath of the wild is massive
and a great place to truly express a
sense of freedom the game gives you
but if you're exploring the same area in
the sequel how will that work for people
who have poured hundreds of hours into
the original
that sense of discovery will be gone
we're hoping that breath of the wild 2
has some sort of termina or coholint
island if it does take place in the same
hyrule
or at the very least has a dark world or
some sort of low rule variant
where things are mostly the same but
slightly different
swimming upgrades as much as the ground
and air movement was an astounding feat
in breath of the wild
i felt like swimming was somewhat of an
afterthought it was fairly clunky to
move quickly and there wasn't a dive
option
and we know the developers put so much
effort into making breath of the wild's
environment so beautiful
even unexplorable areas such as lowland
villages bay so
why weren't we able to explore it you
don't even have to let us fully dive
even the good old iron boost method
would be an interesting addition
return the dark nut there are plenty of
colorful other enemies and the zelda
series that should make a showing in the
breath of the wild sequel but our
personal vouch is for the return of dark
nuts
lynels were an amazing challenge in
breath of the wild but a good
old-fashioned tough one-on-one duel with
metal and metal action
is something that would bring a tear to
my eye in both twilight princess and
wind waker they're one of our favorite
enemies to fight
pet dogs enough said if we can't bed
dogs in the sequel
it's basically unplayable in all
seriousness though the dogs are pretty
darn cute and the feed for treasure
mechanic was cool but
just let me pet the good boys they
deserve it
so there you have it we're so excited
for the breath of the wild sequel that
we just can't stop thinking about it
what do you guys want to see in rest of
the world too
let us know in the comments below and
stay tuned for gamespot for any future
updates on breath of the wild 2.